Scarecrow said he had a plan that
together we could take you out and
Gotham would be ours over my dead body I
believe that was the idea in this game
scarecrow comes to destroy Batman
basically every aspect of Batman is
challenged every aspect of his identity
is challenged Alfred analyzed the
militia forces troop deployments
equipment movements I want to know
exactly what I'm up against this part of
the trilogy is a much more psychological
challenge for Batman he's being ripped
apart and he's fighting for his identity
for me as an actor it was a blast to get
to flex those muscles where is he
talk or I'll crush every bone in your
body the only people left on the streets
of the sort that enjoy the chaos scum
criminals and worse Commissioner Gordon
is both a father a friend and obviously
someone who is trying to save his city
it took just 24 hours for us to lose
control of the city tonight
Gotham's relying on one man to save us
all Gordon has monumental respect for
the bat they're tight they're friends
and they're dedicated and loyal to each
other do you really think scarecrows
crazy enough to detonate a chemical
weapon and Gotham I won't let that
happen Jim Gotham
this is your only warning one more time
because I left a word hurt yes the man's
a psychopath seriously but he's also
brilliant he's actually quite a
reasonable man and the way he talks but
he's obviously very disturbed this
demonstration used just five ounces of
my latest toxin tomorrow will seem like
child's play
it's been an interesting character to
approach because I don't sort of get to
use one of the the monster voices that
you sometimes get the years in in games
so we've got to sort of get that
incredible eeriness of the voice without
overdoing it all that remains is for you
to watch as I drag your beloved Gotham
into oblivion in this particular game he
draws together all here the villains
that we've met over the last 75 years
and brings him into one place to finally
try and bring Batman down if one desire
is not to kill Batman but to humiliate
him to reduce him to ashes and death he
has nothing left to fear your vengeance
will come
what scarecrow works out is that if he
couldn't make Batman feel fear then who
look won the day because then he will
expose him to the world as a fraud
Oracle I need a location of unit 247
this is not the first game that Barbara
Gordon has been in you've heard her
voice and the past but this is actually
the first game where you get to see her
I also get to play Oracle and it's when
Barbara is in a wheelchair and you get
to see just more of her kind of
intellect come out and see how she's
able to kind of guide Batman behind the
scenes or go check the chemical analysis
I've just uploaded hmm it's gonna take a
little while longer drop by the clock
tower when you're ready and I'll show
you what I've got so far
how's my dad doing he's holding up
somehow he always does the relationship
between Barbara Gordon and Commissioner
Gordon it's a loving relationship but
it's secretive I hate lying to him he'd
kill me if he knew I was still in the
city she kind of put the holds a bit of
information because he would never want
his daughter involved with what Batman's
to him because it's so dangerous so you
know I think she keeps her secrets from
him to protect him from worrying about
her sorry I've got to go
stay safe Barbara the biggest surprise
about the game is it this is the first
time that you actually get to drive the
Batmobile you know and all the other
games they get to be the bat but in this
one you actually get to drive this
vehicle and that's something that they
haven't done before so I think they'll
have a lot of fun with that I need to
track that military vehicle the
Batmobile is such an awesome part it's
the most beautiful I've seen it you're
in it you know you're in the Batmobile
you're in the chases it's great perhaps
the main reason I wanted to play
scarecrow is because I hope he might get
to drive the Batmobile and no one does
that wouldn't let me say for you to say
I was a character the joke I'm not
saying it's happening that would be
incorrect to do we're trying to make
this absolutely great
just seeing the landscape of Gotham
seeing what so these characters are I
want to look at that I mean it's
impressive mutually it's astonishing
it's always exciting to be at the
cutting edge of things and I just feel
like this game is really at the cutting
edge
it's astounding that's a beautiful
beautiful world that they created it's
just very very complex and I I did not
expect that
[Music]
you